وين بدنا نروح يجوا ياخذونا بقى يتذمر
اللبنانيون من ازمه اقتصاديه هي الاسوا في
تاريخ البلاد حلت عليهم في 2019 صنفها
البنك الدولي من بين الاسوا منذ عام
وبينما يغص لبنان بازمه سيوله حاده تبرز
قضيه النصف مليار دولار ونعني بها قضيه
الرياض سلامه حاكم المصرف المركزي المتهم
بالتورط في جرائم رشوه وغسل اموال واختلاس
وتهريب وفي كل مره تتحرك القضيه ينفي
سلامه الادعاءات قائلا انها محاوله لجعله
كبش فداء بسبب الازمه الماليه في لبنان
ومن هذه البوابه كان من المقرر ان يدخل
جلسه تحقيق اوروبيه لكنه تغيب عنها وعليه
ارجات السلطات القضائيه الموعده للخميس
لكن وزاره العدل طالبت بالقبض على حاكم
المصرف المركزي وشقيقه رجا مساعدته مريم
الحويك وحجز املاكهم خمس دول اوروبيه على
الاقل وبقائمه تضم 100 سؤال على ثلاثه
ايام سيتولى طرحها قاضي التحقيق الاول في
بيروت شربل ابو سمره وتركز التحقيقات
الاخيره على العلاقه بين مصر في لبنان
وشركه مسجله في الجزر العذراء يعتقد انها
لعبت دور الوسيط لشراء سندات خزينه عبر
تلقي عموله اكتتاب جرى تحويلها الى حسابات
رجا سلامه في الخارج وقبل عام اعلنت وحده
التعاون القضائي الاوروبيه ان فرنسا
والمانيا و لوكسمبورغ جمدت 120 مليون يورو
من الاصول اللبنانيه اثر تحقيق استهدف
سلامه واربعه من المقربين منه بتهم غسل
اموال بقيمه اكثر من 330 مليون دولار
وخمسه ملايين يورو على التوالي بين 2002 و